foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster well we're two
days away from an announcement that
could Define the listro's government
after just three weeks in office
Friday's so-called mini budget sounds
like it will be nothing of the sort with
very big measures on tax and spending
well just today we found out the
treasury could spend a cool 25 billion
pounds to cut energy bills for business
meanwhile the war in Ukraine has taken a
Sinister turn as Vladimir Putin
mobilized more troops and made thilly
veiled threats about using nuclear
weapons
the period of national mourning is over
but the greatest tests for the new prime
minister still lie ahead so there is
lots for us to talk about as we bring
you takes from all sides over the next
60 minutes
you're prepared to be unpopular aren't
you yes yes I am
well we'll look at what unpopular
decisions May mean for the UK economy
and we'll also be discussing this
chilling warning from the Kremlin if
there is a threat to the territorial
Integrity of our country and for
protecting our people we will certainly
use all the means available to us and
I'm not bluffing
well there have been protests on the
streets of Moscow and Resolute words
from Western leaders today we'll be
discussing as well the ongoing cost of
living crisis here in the UK and what
the government plans to do about it with
our viewers panel there they all are for
us this evening great to have you uh on
today's show we'll also have some top
guests including the business secretary
Jacob riesmorg Labor's Shadow leveling
up secretary Lisa nandi
the chief executive of the resolution
Foundation Torsten Bell the former UK
ambassador to Nato sir Adam Thompson
plus we'll be talking to the former
conservative Minister Helen Whiteley and
much more besides all coming up on the
take
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good evening all in the name of economic
growth Liz truss says she's prepared to
take unpopular decisions with that mini
Budget on Friday looks set to contain a
few lifting the cap on Bankers bonuses
for example we're also expecting
personal and business tax cuts plus
there are rumors of a cut to stamp Duty
the new prime minister certainly isn't
hanging around let's have a look at
what's happened in her first few weeks
in office
this is the moment to be bold we are
facing a global energy crisis and there
are no cost free options
the Firearms officer who fatally shot
Chris Carver in South London last week
has been suspended for the family
welcomed the iopc's decision today to
launch a homicide investigation the
ukrainians have taken as we say large
swathes of territory if there is a
threat to the territorial Integrity of
our country we will certainly use all
the means available to us and I'm not
bluffing we'll stand in solidarity
against Russia's aggression period now
Liz truss is at the United Nations in
New York for her first foreign trip as
prime minister you're prepared to be
unpopular aren't you yes yes I am we
want to work more closely uh with the
United States but also in reaching out
to fellow democracies around the world
and we protect the freedom and future of
our citizens
we've got a little bit of breaking news
to bring you right now because we have
just had the official readout of prime
minister Liz truss's meeting with that
with the U.S president uh Joe Biden
unsurprisingly they're talking about the
response to Vladimir Putin's comments
they said that they condemned Putin's
recent belligerent statements on Ukraine
they agreed his actions highlight the
need for allies to continue their
economic and Military Support to Ukraine
and the Prime Minister updated President
Biden on her recent announcement that
the UK will recommit to at least the
same level of Defense support for
Ukraine next year at least the same
level there they also talked about the
need to end the over-reliance as they
put it on authoritarian States in terms
of energy and to try and reduce energy
dependence on Russia as specifically and
then finally they also discussed the
Northern Ireland protocol something of
course that has been a matter of
contention for the two on the Northern
Ireland protocol the Prime Minister and
President Biden both agreed that the
priority must be protecting the Belfast
agreement The Good Friday agreement and
preserving the gains of Peace in
Northern Ireland so that is the readout
from A Downing Street spokesperson for
that meeting
well today the government confirmed it
will be holding down the prices of gas
and electricity for businesses hospitals
schools and Charities this winter well
that could cost some 25 billion pounds
and it's on top of the 120 billion it
could cost to keep bills down for
domestic customers over the next 18
months a little earlier I spoke to
business secretary Jacob rees-mogg given
today's developments I did start by
asking about Vladimir Putin's threats of
Ukraine
well I I think Putin's response is one
that is worrying that the war has not
been going well for him and therefore he
is effectively doubling down but as the
Prime Minister has said we stand Four
Square behind the people of Ukraine and
want them to succeed so I think we've
got to carry on giving off full support
to the people of Ukraine and hope that
Putin will realize that his illegal war
is doing damage to the whole of Russia
and is not in the interests of the
Russian people and will not ultimately
be successful
uh thank you I'm just moving on to
domestic policy now and today you've set
out your energy plan to specifically
help businesses just explain to us the
policy and the idea behind it
well essentially we will provide for
businesses the support that we've
provided for domestic gas and
electricity users and indeed people on
heating oil that is to ensure that
prices remain at an affordable level now
domestic users it was relatively
straightforward because there was
already a price cap and they're
relatively small number of suppliers the
business Market is much more complicated
and therefore we have had to come up
with a solution that caps wholesale
prices which will feed through to the
non-domestic sector and that includes
Charities and Care Homes hospitals and
schools as well as businesses and the
freeze that you introduced today lasts
for six months you know if you're a head
teacher or a hospital manager really
worried about what happens if Energy
prices remain as high as they are now in
six months time what reassurance can you
give them
the reassurance I would give is that yes
it is announced for six months but there
will be a review in three months to see
how the scheme is working we've
introduced very rapidly a very broad
brush scheme that is covering uh every
user of energy with actually The Only
Exception being
gas fired power stations they're the
only exemption from this help for
obvious reasons what we want to do is to
review how it's working see whether that
is the right approach to support whether
it should be more targeted but I think I
can give some reassurance that at these
levels the government is very well aware
that schools hospitals hospices Care
Homes and many businesses would not be
able to cope with the level of fuel
prices that we currently have okay that
does give a general sort of indication
about your thinking on it
the other question I have is about how
it's going to be paid for what costings
have you done
well these will be announced by the
chancellor in the fiscal event on Friday
so I don't want to preempt him but this
is a very expensive scheme
this is the right thing to do because
the cost whether it falls on the
taxpayer or on individuals and
businesses is very substantial it is a
substantial cost for the whole economy
but the unfortunate truth is that if
this were to fall on individuals and
onto businesses many would not be able
to afford it businesses would not be
able to continue in operation but the
government shoulders are broader and
stronger and that in a sense is what
government is for is to pick up the
burdens that individuals cannot bear and
that is what we're doing the cost would
hit the economy one way or another
anyway but it's being taken on
collectively rather than falling on
individuals and and non-domestic users
you know I have to say it's quite
interesting listening to you talking
about the broad shoulders of the
government to you you know Jacob Reese
morgue you know and again Liz truss is
someone who spent the leadership
election telling us that she was going
to govern like a conservative and yet
really she's announced one of the
radical State intervention policies the
kind of thing that would make Jeremy
corbyn blush
well you have to think what is the state
there for fundamentally and it seems to
me that the state should lead leave us
alone to lead our own lives as much as
possible
but there are certain things that
individuals cannot do for themselves and
that may be law and order it may be The
Fountains of the realm but in this
circumstance seeing it is bearing a
burden that has because actually a
Putin's illegal uh War become unbearable
so the state is there when the
individual can't bear the burden and
otherwise of course it should lead leave
the individual to get home with his or
her own life so I think this actually
fits a fundamentally conservative view
of the role of the state it's the
um uh last um
bearer of burdens
Cornwall Insight reckons that it could
cost 25 billion pounds is that in the
right region
you're trying to tempt me to prevent the
chancellor and I think that would be
discourteous of me I I must leave the
chancellor to make his announcement on
Friday understood now Liz truss has also
said that this is a government all about
growth we know the tax cutting agenda
that she wants to set out do you think
there's also a case for looking at
employment law perhaps scrapping the
48-hour week
well I think we should look at
regulations particularly in the context
of retained EU law to see what
regulations are suitable for economic
growth and which ones aren't we now have
the freedom to decide that and that's
one of the benefits of brexit but it's
too early to announce any specific
policies but I'm looking forward to the
retained EU law bill being introduced
into Parliament shortly which will have
a expedited process for repealing
Unnecessary EU laws
do you think that the 48-hour week then
could be an unnecessary EU law
um well you said that not me I I'm I
think it's certainly something that
people will raise I don't want to
preempt decisions that haven't been made
um but we have to look at whether we
have the right system of regulation in
this country to maximize economic growth
Capri smoke uh their business secretary
well let's get Labor's take on all that
now shall we ahead of the parties
conference which starts this weekend our
Sunday show is going to be live from
that conferencer in Liverpool where
we're joined Now by The Shadow leveling
up secretary Lisa Nando thank you for
being with us and we've just been
listening to the Jacob free smog
interview I was quite interested what he
said about the working week the 48-hour
week as some regulation we should look
at all different regulations
particularly those under EU law do you
agree with them I I didn't hear the
precise thing that he said about the
48-hour week but I certainly got the
general thrust that this is a government
that is going to try to deregulate in
order to fuel growth in the economy I
think the problem for them is that a lot
of these ideas have been tried before
we've already had Rishi sunak for
example trying to scrap or lower stamp
Duty during the pandemic it just pushed
up house prices it didn't help
first-time buyers in fact there was
quite a bit of evidence that it made
housing affordability worse I think the
government really does need to think
seriously about not just what help
they're going to provide but who pays
for that help that was the big
unanswered question from that interview
that you just did with the business
secretary everybody accepts that
businesses families need help this
winter the question is are we going to
tax the profits of people who've done
well in the last few years or are we
going to load more and more of that cost
onto struggling small businesses and
struggling families across the country
as you say it is an answer question
still we are asking it Jacob response
says look we've got to wait till Friday
which I guess is two days away
um to find out exactly how they do a
plan to pay from it and what else are
you looking forward for on Friday well
we've got we've got to have a plan to
help people now and we've got to make
sure that the burden falls on those who
are most able to Bear it so you know as
we've put forward plans to raise the
digital sales tax for example so that
the big internet Giants pay a bit more
we think that would raise about two
billion pounds we could use half of that
to help energy intensive Industries who
are really struggling right now and the
other half as a fund to raise the
threshold for business rates relief so
that a lot of small businesses will be
taken out of business rates altogether
and others would find that they had help
with other costs at a time when Energy
prices are soaring those are the sort of
proposals that we want to see the
government bringing forward not more of
this loading more of the costs
displacing them onto businesses and
families who are already struggling by
higher taxis for a very long period of
time we want to see fairness in the
system and that's what the government
has to answer I mean I guess what
they're trying to do with business isn't
it is to try and remove some of that tax
burden as well particularly in this the
uh the investment zones as well
potentially slashing taxes for business
and even potentially for workers as well
in deprived areas to try and boost
growth is that something you think would
be a good idea well this isn't a new
idea so this is an idea that's been
around for a very long time it was tried
under the last Labor government George
Osborne it was his big idea in 2011 and
we still still got a lot of these
they're called Enterprise zones at the
moment they're being renamed investment
zones the problem with what the
government is briefing is that these are
not particularly focused on deprived
areas and the areas that have them don't
necessarily benefit doesn't seem that
they'll get to keep any proceeds of
growth that are developed there and if
if what Jacob Reese MOG was hinting at
is what eventually materializes the
situation for people in these zones
could get far far worse if you're
essentially saying to some businesses
you can come in you won't pay any taxes
other businesses are going to have to
take the strain you're going to displace
the amount of tax burden on some other
businesses but also you're gonna you're
gonna cause real problems because if
they're not paying towards the
infrastructure in those places for the
roads and the the schools and all of the
things that sustain a place who is going
to pay for it it's probably going to be
taxpayers so you know government needs
to think really seriously about this
because they've been warned by every
senior Economist that the plans that
they're currently briefing out aren't
going to create the growth that they
need I uh just wonder though when you
were talking about growth there the one
thing you can say about this government
is we know what they stand for growth
right you can sum it up in a word we can
argue about whether or not it's going to
be effective or if it's going to work or
not but we know the policy principle
that they stand for every policy is
around that
what does labor stand for look we've
been pushing the government to get a
growth strategy since the beginning so
growth is that what you stand for but
but but actually Sophie I would question
this because I you know I went into the
first prime minister's questions with
Liz truss and I think it was absolutely
clear who she stood for she stands for
the few and not the many that's why
she's loading the cost of the energy
proposals onto people and hard-working
families not onto office everyone and we
can have obviously there is clearly a
debate about whether or not that is true
or not but we know that this is a
government that is ideologically we can
see what it is they believe in growth
only benefits everybody if everybody
gains but she has no plan to share the
proceeds of that growth she doesn't
believe in redistribution she believes
in raising the cap on Bankers bonuses
but opposing pay Rises that are in line
with inflation for working people it
just doesn't stack up and in the end
that will be the thing that undoes her
unless she changes course before Friday
and we very much hope she does I am Keen
to talk about Ukraine it's such a big
story many of our views can be really
concerned about what Ed Putin's been
saying he's called up 300 000 military
reservists it's the biggest mobilization
since World War one would labor be doing
anything differently if you were in
government now we make no apology for
the fact that the political parties in
Britain are united about our response to
Putin we have to stand up to Russian
aggression we have to stand very closely
with our allies in Europe and the United
States and our NATO Partners as well in
order to send a very clear and
unequivocal message to Putin and I
listened to Liz trust today it's a very
welcome change of tack from the approach
that this government has taken for the
last 12 years finally taking Russian
aggression seriously the next bit of
this jigsaw is that they've got to take
seriously the influence of the Russian
government in the United States they've
got to clean up illicit Finance in the
city of London and stop proposing
measures which they've currently got
that they're trying to get through the
statute book to make it easier for
foreign money to influence our politics
would you raised defense spending and I
think it's right to look at defense
spending at the moment you know I
haven't seen the exact details of what
they're proposing but we've always been
very supportive of the idea that you
need to have a baseline of defense
spending which you know until recently
there was a consensus around a minimum
of two percent I think that defense is
one of those things that people often
think is an add-on but look at what is
happening so would you like it to go to
three percent then I think we've got to
make sure that our troops have and our
intelligence Services have exactly what
they need in order to deal with the
threats that we Face we've got a lot of
States at the moment displaying
extremely aggressive behavior in lots of
parts of the world but to have Russia
behaving like this on the edge of our
own neighborhood means that we've got to
take this seriously okay thank you very
much for being on program Nathan Andy
they're right well let's take a moment
shall we and try and work out what we've
learned so far we are joined with our
deputally uh Sam Coates uh loitering it
in the wings listening to those
interviews there I'm sure not offering
at all too okay what is your main
takeaways from what we've had so far
well it's really striking Sophie that
here we are in the middle of a
parliament quite a long time since the
general election quite a long time until
we assume the next general election and
we are seeing we are seeing a massive
shift in Direction huge change in the
way that Britain is going to be governed
here we are what three weeks into Liz
truss's Premiership massive tax cuts to
be announced on Friday massive scrapping
of rules broad hint to you from Jacob
Reese mug that they would get rid of the
48-hour working week EU direct working
time directive which has been across the
many uh brexiteers have wanted to see
scrap but also huge spending which you
wouldn't necessarily associate with free
marketeers like Liz truss and Jacob
riesmog on a scale that perhaps might
actually unnerve the market raising
questions about just how safe it is to
borrow uh and to um to borrow UK guilt
UK government debt so that's a big
change from what we saw under Boris
Johnson with a new team in number 10 not
afraid to tell well the old Boris
Johnson lot that they got it wrong Liz
truss out in New York this week saying
I'm not uh I'm totally prepared to be
unpopular so we've got more of an
ideological divide than we have had I
think at any point in the last few years
but this is both a opportunity and a
challenge for Lisa and Andy what was
striking about how she addressed it is
that neighbor have to work quite hard I
think to shift uh their response to this
some of the answers she was giving not
really taking account of the new energy
policies announced by Jacob reesemug
today you heard her talking about money
for energy intensive Industries well
today the government said that they were
going to basically freeze the energy
bills of those sorts of companies so
quite why they're still talking about
that I wasn't clear but how is kirst
armor at Labor conference uh in
Liverpool from sassy going to use that
new space that's opened up well I think
that's a very big question for him
possibly one that will determine his
future yeah it's really interesting it
feels like there's a real Clash of
ideologies at it are going on perhaps
the attacks on Boris Johnson from labor
we're more about competence and delivery
well now it's ideology thank you so much
at Sam coats there
now as we've been discussing uh tonight
Vladimir Putin is mobilizing some 300
000 additional troops it's the biggest
since the second world war as his forces
struggle in Ukraine or some 800 people
have been arrested in Russia Today in
protests against the war so just how
dangerous is the cornered Russian
president and what can the West do now
well we can speak now to Sir Adam
Thompson the former UK ambassador to
Nato and director of the European
leadership Network thank you so much for
being with us oh let's just put that
question to you how dangerous is
Vladimir Putin right now
well it's getting more dangerous
certainly I don't think we're yet at the
worst of this crisis which has got
really quite a long way to go not just
through a difficult winter but also into
a new fighting season in the spring and
summer of next year
his nuclear threats are designed to try
and frighten the West in particular and
split it off from its support for
Ukraine but we haven't yet as far as I
am aware seeing any heightened Russian
state of alert for its nuclear forces
for example and there are plenty of
other steps that Putin can take to
escalate this situation short of actual
use of a nuclear weapon so
it's more of the same in a sense of
Russia uh trying to use use its nuclear
power status to steal territory but it
isn't yet I think a really actual threat
I suspect that although Putin is in a
difficult spot he probably does half
believe that this partial mobilization
will make a difference and it might
indeed prolong the conflict but I don't
think it will change the direction of
travel because Russia depends not just
on men and most of these new ones will
be poorly trained but also on weaponry
and ammunition and he's already been
reduced to buying uh weaponry and
ammunition from North Korea
um you mentioned a little earlier in
your answer saying that there are steps
that Putin can take to escalate the
conflict that aren't uh the use of a
nuclear weapon what kind of steps are
you talking about
he can uh even more aggressively than he
has done already Target not just uh
Ukrainian civilian targets but Ukrainian
infrastructure uh has already been
playing around with the risks to nuclear
power plants but there's much more he
can do to [ __ ] the Ukrainian economy
if he puts his mind to it and he can
also uh God forbid but try and Target uh
Ukrainian decision makers you know
president zielinski himself and Targets
in Kiev that have been left untouched
for quite a number of months now so uh
there's really I repeat
a long way to go uh Putin will be hoping
uh uh desperately I think increasingly
desperately that by squeezing Europe on
energy this winter and threatening uh
dire retribution if anyone body touches
Russian territory he will start sowing
doubts and split Western cohesion
breaking Europe and the United States
away from Ukraine that's his goal and I
think he still believes he can achieve
it even though he's clearly in a
considerable domestic political crisis
on Friday last he was saying that he had
no change of plans and now he's done
something that we know from Western
intelligence sources he really really
did not want to do which is at least
partial mobilization which makes the war
so much more real for uh people in the
big Russian cities like Moscow and Saint
Petersburg I'm interested in what could
happen within Russia we will talk about
the number of people you know arrested
in Russia you're speaking there about
how the Walker become more unpopular
because of this mobilization and what do
you think the interaction in Russia
could be and is there a chance I guess
that it could be some kind of Uprising
in Russia that tries to stop the war or
even you know overthrows Putin I guess
well this is an increasingly fluid
crisis for all concerned and so I
suppose it's rashed to rule out any
scenario but uh President Putin uh has a
good KGB officer has a very very very
good grip uh on security uh in Russia
and I don't think Uprising is
particularly likely but we have just
seen him cave in on a critical policy
matter to Russian Hawks who are even
further to the right of him so he is
politically vulnerable even if he's not
facing a a palace coup or uh popular
demonstrations that get out of control
uh and uh I I feel that in some ways his
announcement today it marks the
beginning of a of a long slow uh end to
the Putin era
that's interesting to to hear um your
assessment of how he is politically and
the strength that he has uh politically
uh in Moscow
um what as far as you're aware is a
situation on the ground we've obviously
had these uh weeks where we've been told
about these very strong Ukrainian
advancements then other reports that
perhaps there's more resistance from
Russia than they were finding initially
what's your assessment of where the war
is at
my uh I'm not I don't have any uh great
Insight knowledge but my impression is
that uh the uh the scale of the Russian
uh uh withdrawal has been more damaging
politically than militarily some Russian
forces have withdrawn in good order uh
they're perhaps now on better defended
lines than they were before and it's
quite likely that in the Northeast the
ukrainians are going to find it
difficult to make significant further
advances between now and when winter
descends and it gets a bit more
difficult and Ukrainian capacity really
runs out so uh I I think the ukrainians
have done what they needed to do before
the winter which is to persuade their
Western backers that they can win they
can make progress uh provided they are
supported economic atomically and
militarily by the west but we may not
see much more in the way of a big change
on the ground for some months to come
now okay thank you very much it's been
really interesting to talk and getting
your insights thank you
thank you
you are watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
we'll be talking to our viewers panel to
find out what people at home make up
what they've heard so far
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back we're live in
Westminster and you're watching the take
well now we're just two days away from
what could be a very significant
so-called mini Budget on Friday it
probably won't be many at all so I think
it's a good time to bring in our viewers
panel and find out well what they'd like
to hear from the chancellor but also to
try and get a bit of a sense of how
people around the country are really
finding at the inflation crisis that we
are seeing great to have you all uh here
thank you for being with us
um let's go to sleep first shall we
speak Thacker are you talking to us from
uh Leicester
um how worried have you been about the
cost of living
previously
um yeah I agree with you
I've been getting it all in
so I also live in an Old Town House
and uh we the service charges
of training Authority or Industries
the energy devices
and the prices have come
come and come down
it's me I'm I'm so sorry
um your microphone is is breaking up for
us and I did get the gist of what you're
saying you're talking about fuel prices
uh being really really high the prices
of the pump been difficult and obviously
you're traveling for work as you say as
well but I'm I'm gonna have to stop you
there just because the sound isn't quite
good enough for us to go on we will try
and come back to you later if possible
let's go to John Instead at shall we
John you're talking to us from Kent now
you're a pensioner aren't you and how
are you finding the cost of living
crisis
I'm I'm coping but uh you know quite
well but there's a lot of people
and I think the government needs to
do something more importantly the
pensioners are purely
um they've already
taken away the triple lock to help the
only
pensioners are going to connect
uh unless they're disabled like that but
um is the increase in the um
plus obviously the four everybody else
and when you take into account and
there's a lot of Pensions living on
their own
purely living
those people are gonna
good point isn't it about those people
as you say who are struggling pensioners
in particular who won't necessarily
benefit from some of the help announced
right let's bring in Lisa at shall we
Lisa Goddard who is talking to us from
uh Birmingham today Lisa at Lisa how
reassured have you been at the mg price
announcement we heard a bit from Jacob
reesemang earlier
uh I'm relieved that we've got an idea
of what's coming and that we've got a
future prize and I've been really
worried about the uh energy bills and
concerned about fuel I am pleased we've
got a fixed price I'm concerned about
only I've been to six months for
businesses uh
what that'll mean for ongoing impacts
with disability I'm not sure
exactly and it really is a concern for
people isn't it but as you say good to
get a bit of a direction of travel on
what you're doing on NG okay we can talk
to uh Roz next Aur Ros and our roles I
know you're a former head teacher a
national leader in education and
obviously lots of heads in the minute
are going to be really worried about
schools Jacob reusable seeming to
suggest that the help will be extended
at past six months but you know
certainly a worrying time
yes I'm very worried for schools
because
the thing is we're not we weren't in a
good place our schools were not in a
great place none of our Public Services
have been in a good place now for a very
long time
so the help is very welcome
but
one of the things that's happened
recently is that school teachers have
been awarded a pair as a much deserved
pay rise which everybody's very pleased
they've got but it's unfunded
now School budgets are under tremendous
pressure the help with energy caused the
welcome
but I know I train the head teachers all
over the country
and everybody is talking about their
stress and their worry about budgets and
the pressure on school budgets
we're seeing an attrition rate of school
leaders now
people are not coming forward vacancies
budgets don't balance actually public
services
are really facing a crisis but an
education service but if we listen to
everybody in the Health Service what
they're saying is actually this crisis
that they're facing it's not about covid
it's because they weren't in a fit State
even before covid our public services
are literally on their means that should
be the priority of this government okay
thank you so much for talking to us
today Ross there at strong feelings
they're on schools and more worthy about
public sector as well and we can bring
in Chloe now let's bring in Chloe Forest
at shall we you're a nurse you're
talking to us from Cumbria and I know
you're a conservative though she voted
for uh Boris Johnson although you kind
of I guess towards the end of the last
series of the program you were
questioning whether or not he was the
right man for the job um what do you
make of Liz Truss
um to be honest I'm not a fan I think
it's very concerning with the prime
minister in the military isn't that
bothered if she'd like to or not and you
know if she's got the support of the
people that she's leading
um and then I mean at this part of you
know we've got Paris coffee that doesn't
really ever know what's going on and
just ever have any answers to anything
so that concerns me a little bit
um whether you just don't want to care
like other people in the past have I
think it's more of a what you can be and
and a bit of a show
and which which it worries me a little
bit to be honest would you vote for her
just quickly
pardon would you vote for her
no okay interesting well let's bring in
our other concept of beta shall we let's
bring in Roy Roya uh from Kent uh Roy do
you agree uh on Kobe's assessment of Liz
Truss
um no I'm I'm completely opposite I
think I I was
um doubtful of her to begin with but I
must admit
um right from the get-go prime
minister's questions her first one
um she surprised me and since then she's
been
pretty good actually
um I like her the way that she's she's
pulled together the cabinet the people
that she's put in cabinet the mix of
cabinet in terms of diversity there are
more black people in there I can see
some white people shaking their heads
but do you know what we've been waiting
for a while to get some better
representation
um the people she's put in uh Jacob
Reese smoke just now just screamed
common sense as far as I'm concerned
um there are many people who are
not liking him mainly because of his
background you know I don't have blue
eyes do I get upset about somebody who
didn't pick their eyes
he didn't pick his background he just
happened to have been born into that
background and he made the best of it I
was born into what I had and I tried the
best I could to make the best of what I
had
so
um
I'm quite
quite hopeful I think Britain needs to
get its Swagger back that's that's the
problem we talk the country down too
much okay
um
great to have you yeah great to hear
diversity reviews number one I've got
you uh this we've got splits in opinion
on trust with our two conservative
voters but if I was going to ask you all
and remember you know we have got I
think it's three labor three
conservatives so we're gonna have you
know that just to bear in mind uh with a
panel if you've all got a pen and paper
by you I'd like you to write have a
think and write down a word that comes
into your mind when I asked you about
Liz truss what word would you say sums
up Liz truss we're on TV obviously so
keep it clean please I'm trusting you
guys here
um
always really interesting to take the
take the temperature of what everyone
thinks right we're getting a couple of
questions now uh through we have one
nuts being held held up
surprising from Roy obviously uh in a
good way
um inconsistent uh so says
um one of our panelists a delusional
from Chloe not a fan of evil is trust
there out of her depth uh from uh sweet
and questionable so a real range of
views here uh thank you so much always
great fun to talk to you and thanks for
being good sports today on the panel
now what is Saturn is the Liz Liz trust
Premiership is likely to see return to
ideological economic policy in a way we
haven't seen in the UK for decades
because the new prime minister has made
it very clear she's not interested at
who gets what as long as the overall
economy gets bigger so we're expecting
tax cuts but also borrowing with tens of
billions of pounds of spending on energy
bills support
well let's speak to the chief executive
of the resolution Foundation Torsten
Bell for his view on today's
announcements uh thank you so much for
being with us you tweeted earlier today
to say that Friday's mini budget won't
be remotely many big tax cuts big tax
reforms big increases in borrowing what
are you expecting
well we're expecting a big package as I
was spelling out I mean this trust has
already said and she's committed to very
large tax cuts those are to corporation
tax and to National Insurance mainly
that's about saying that she doesn't
agree with the tax Rises that rashes to
enact either put in place or was about
to put in place when he was chanting so
she's got a big package there on top of
that obviously the global economy
developments with gas prices means she's
already put in place very big measures
increasing borrowing very significantly
over this year and next to pay for
support for households and the support
for businesses that you've been
discussing on the program this evening
and then on top of that we've got a
deterioration in the economy which means
that we're seeing higher interest rates
and higher inflation and that will lead
to higher borrowing on its own so the
combination of all three of those means
that what we're going to learn about on
Friday is a very very big increase in
government borrowing and how concerned
should we be or not about a big increase
in government borrowing
I mean your listeners and viewers are
probably used to hearing over the last
few years very large borrowing figures
because that's how we got through the
pandemic and obviously the financial
crisis before that also included large
amounts of borrowing as we had to
nationalize uh some of our biggest banks
so I think you know there are reasons
you need to do that I think what we're
seeing though is a choice here it it's
pretty much unavoidable that we were
going to be doing more borrowing as the
economy slowed but also that we would do
more borrowing to cope with these truly
exceptional increases energy prices I
think it's completely reasonable that
the government's saying look some of
these energy price Rises are likely to
be temporary and so borrowing from
tomorrow's taxpayers to help today's
Bill payers makes good sense what
they're doing on top of that though is
not doing as much as they could to
mitigate how much borrowing that helped
with energy bills requires either by
going further on winful taxes or
actually by capping the windfalls that
companies are making particularly
renewable or nuclear electricity
generators who are seeing big windfalls
even though they don't have anything to
do with uh gas oil production and then
on top of that she's saying Now's the
Time for large for lower taxes than my
predecessor thought we needed so there's
things that are unavoidable about higher
borrowing but then on top of that she's
making choices not to minimize some of
the increase in borrowing and then on
top of that to to choose to have lower
taxes too I mean I guess what Liz
trusts's uh Team would say is that this
is all part of trying to inject growth
into the economy so lower track taxes
they hope will stimulate uh growth some
of the energy changes will help bring
down inflation all of these things will
a good news for the economy I mean do
you think there's Merit in that argument
was definitely Merit in saying it's a
good idea for the British government to
be focused on growth the last 15 years
have been a period of relative decline
for the UK economy we've been outgrown
by most other major advanced economies
and that is making us all poorer put the
bottom the middle and the top are all
worse off because of that slowdown in
our economy so she's right to focus on
that and she's right to say that that
will involve doing some unpopular things
cutting taxes isn't actually that
unpopular a thing you're um recognizing
also the level of Taxation isn't the
most important thing in determining your
growth rates lots of the economies that
have grown faster than us have higher
rates of tax and the United States has
significantly lowered rates of tax and
has grown fast enough so I think the
role of tax in driving economic growth
is understated compared to for example
firms being able to build things when
they want to or us having the right
levels of skills for our Workforce or
indeed the right numbers of workers and
actually firms investing is important
for our growth rates but it isn't really
lower corporation tax that tends to
drive that I just want to have a look at
a couple of charts if I may and the
first one is this is from the resolution
foundation so hopefully be quite
familiar with them the first one shows
the impact of the policy changes
introduced by Liz trust in
2022-23 and then just quickly to go to
the next one because this is the one
that's really interesting the second
year 2023 to four really shows here how
the planned policy changes do
disproportionately help richer
households so if you like if you like
the ones towards a richer scale the
number 10 at the richest households are
benefiting most from those policy
changes
I mean let's trust at least has been
quite open about this hasn't she to say
that she doesn't necessarily think that
it's a problem if the wealthier
households uh disproportionately benefit
from some of those policies
yeah I mean what those charts show is
firstly there's a lot of support going
in from that's being announced by Liz
trust but was also put in place by the
previous government under Boris Johnson
and Russia students there's a lot of
support going in with a number of
different measures overall this year
that's providing quite a lot of support
to low-income households middle-income
households and high income households is
providing roughly the same support to
all of those income groups even though
obviously it's lower income households
that will be suffering most from rising
energy bills they don't have savings to
draw down on they can't cut back on
expensive holidays to pay the energy
bill now if you look at next year the
chart you're showing now you're right
that when you combine the dropping away
of lots of the support that's more
focused on the bottom in the middle this
year and then you add on top and you
have a energy price guarantee that's the
price cap the 2500 price cap for
households and their energy bills that
goes to everybody but you add on top of
that the big cup to National Insurance
that they're planning to announce on
Friday then it is the higher income
households that see most support next
year they have now this just has said
that the National Insurance rise that
she wants to reverse she recognizes
benefits richer households I think
whether or not you believe in that level
of National Insurance you want it up or
you want it down I think what it
definitely isn't is a good way to Target
support at people during this cost of
living crisis I think there are good
Arguments for a higher level low of
taxes good time thank you very much
indeed uh tolston Bell there well at
torson Bell there are talking about what
he thinks the government may do on
Friday a little earlier we spoke to the
conservative former Minister uh Helen
Whiteley the former exchecker Secretary
of the Treasury to find out what she
thought
the first thing for me as a former
treasury Minister also as a constituency
MP is I know people have been worrying
so much about their energy costs and the
energy bills and the cost of living so
I'm really glad that the first thing
list trusted on this prime minister is
already make a big announcement about
helping people with the cost of energy
through the winter and then today we've
had the announcement on support for
businesses which will be a huge business
will be breathing huge sigh of relief
think about that and knowing that
they're going to get help through the
winter with the energy costs are you
working perhaps could be paid for
oh well of course and you were just
asking me about Friday uh so what I'm
looking forward to seeing on Friday is
the chancellor setting out his plans for
economic growth that's a really big part
of his agenda about our new prime
minister's agenda really really
important to the country we've been
through such difficult times we still
are in difficult times but the best way
through anything we know is for economic
growth that's the best thing for
everybody that's how we get higher wages
job opportunities goes through into
people having more money to spend better
stands of living it looks like we're
going to get some tax cards um some of
them of course have been spoken about
previously and stamp duty is another
that's been floated in the papers today
it's now the right time to cut taxes
given High inflation
that's a good question
um I would say on inflation uh clearly
we do have high inflation right now but
looking ahead and the bank of England is
expecting for inflation to come down of
affecting Energy prices to come down
which I mean particularly you know
particularly driving uh driving that and
we've got the support with the cost of
energy which will help through the
winter on that and then you know in two
years out Bank of England is expecting
inflation to come back down to around
about two percent and there's a clearly
a balance you don't government doesn't
want to do things that drive inflation
but we also have a recessionary risk at
the moment and we don't want to see that
kind of economic slowdown uh we want to
see instead of that we want to see
growth so this is actually the job for
the chancellor but you accept that tax
cuts could fuel inflation uh well
actually I think you know what one of
the benefits of the decisive action
taken by the Prime Minister Chancellor
on uh on energy is that will help
control inflation and clearly
controlling inflation but it is like the
ifs for example says that you know it
could increase inflation well as I said
I mean the the remit of the bank of
England and its independence is to take
steps uh through their policies to
control inflation and they're just set
out
um what they're saying about uh
inflation at the moment and I think we
do have against that the uh the the the
risk of some concern about sort of
recession and the importance of economic
growth so I think actually no I think
it's a really really uh positive agenda
um which I'm looking forward to getting
behind
I'm Keen to ask about fairness as well
um if you look at some of the policies
that we're seeing from Liz truss and
stamp Duty carts corporation tax being
lower than uh plans scrapping the cap on
Bankers bonuses
is this a government that looks like
it's just on the side of the wealthy
well the first thing I'd say on that is
actually if you look back over uh the
last few months uh going back to around
about this time last year last winter
there has been substantial support put
in to help people on Lower incomes this
is prime minister yeah but it's all
still I mean it's worth looking at it in
in the round because these things are
continuing so for instance the support
that was announced before the summer
recess that I was involved in the
treasury and developing that package
which is 1200 pounds to households on
Lower incomes extra help for pensioners
extra 150 pounds of people with their
abilities going out today
what the new prime minister is doing
that these are the policies that she
wants to do stamp Duty corporation tax
cuts or canceling Rises a scrapping caps
on both as bonuses it's a valid question
well but I was just coming to that and
I'd say but I'd say no do look at it in
the round that those steps have been
taken uh particularly to help those on
Lower incomes and in fact some of the
tax cuts that have happened over the
last year for instance a Universal
Credit taper change essentially a tax
cut to those or no incomes so those
things have already happened
um but clearly the way that Liz trust as
prime minister causes Chancellor are
looking this is then really focusing on
economic growth as being the way that
the increase the size of the pie so
overall rather than just saying well you
know there's this is the size of the UK
economy and how do we how do we
redistribute that amongst people to say
well actually let's look at how we can
invest and how we can uh increase the
size of the UK economy and that would be
good for everybody you obviously back
wish you soon in the leadership election
you're sitting here basically because
you can do what you want now you don't
have you're not part of the government
any longer
um do you think you were punished by
backing the wrong horse uh I don't see
that at all I mean what I do see is
looking at a cabinet that Liz truss has
brought together and really talented
people many of my good friends very
capable people the vast majority of them
who backed out for the leadership in
that cabinet oh I mean it's it's it is a
normal thing that somebody who becomes a
leader
um has people who are loyal to them
who've helped them on their Journey
there
um around them are completely completely
understand that but also in a really
talented colleagues uh there's real
diversity but people are there because
they're Merit not because of uh
particularly you know their background I
think that's a real strength of lizard
government and are you enjoying your
newfound Freedom uh so far so good okay
thank you very much indeed thank you so
much
and I won't be there who obviously
backed Rishi soon I didn't get a job in
the Liz trust Administration let's bring
in some coke shall we Grant shout out to
another person who backrested neck what
happened to him two weeks ago he walked
into Liz truss's office to find out
whether or not he was going to be
allowed to stay as transport secretary
I've discovered the contents of that
conversation Liz trust told Grant chaps
you were one of the most competent
secretaries of state and probably the
best Communicator in government but you
didn't back me and there's no room at
the inn and he was out in the cold
probably going to be broadly loyal but I
think that story is whizzing around till
we back benches at the moment because it
makes it very hard for Liz drost to
claim that she's got a government of all
the talents when she says the best
secretaries of state and the best
communicators are on the outside because
they didn't back her there is a sense
there's a bit of dividing rule at the
moment that's not going down well with
parts of the conservative parliamentary
party she hasn't done that myself any
flavors with that anecdote I mean I
guess she says she's prepared to be
unpopular she's being open absolutely uh
Sam thank you very much indeed thank you
it's always good to talk well that is
good for does it for the take we'll be
back next week and every week on
Wednesday at 9 00 p.m and next up it is
Sky News at 10. thanks very much for
watching see you next week
[Music]
there are now two billion people
shopping on laptops and phones 24 hours
in every Zone
if you do business online no need to do
it alone
[Music]
will help you keep up with the clicks
[Music]